[Music]
Me
Wakasa It's
easier for me to get out of here Both of you will follow me and
have a fast battle
.
You do
n't have to worry about the rent,
I
wonder if it's all right,
Seina-sama.  No
matter where you are, it's
okay Ishiran is a clumsy chassis
ranke shufoo I'm pretending to get out of the pal so
I'll really pull it out Help me yeah
[Applause]
Well, from 10 o'clock, it's fun, isn't it? Hey auto
How did you know I was on this island
?  If you don't hurry, it wo
n't look okay No matter how late
Shimadzu is, after
moving forward, it's the ruler Yes, rice is also like Simitai's fella,
isn't it?
Hey, I got hit by a dog's belly
---- --- --- --- --- --- --- ---- Deeta
Quietly use it, young lady!
If you're going to do something, just stitch it with Mr.
Aofuda will
take care
of
it.
[Music]
Say yes, yes, yes, I'm in the
rental car. It
was quiet
.
[music]